was ist 25 000 Mal so klimaschädlich wie
CO2 SF6 ist das stärkste Treibhausgas
das wir kennen aber wusstest du dass es
in Windkraftanlagen als Isolator
eingesetzt wird und heißt das dass
Windräder Schuld an der Klimakrise sind
nein Windräder sind nicht schuld an der
Klimakrise erstens macht die Verwendung
von SF6 in Windkraftanlagen nur einen
kleinen Teil der deutschen Emissionen
aus das zeigt diese Grafik hier die
Emissionen aus Windkraftanlagen fallen
in den pinken Bereich aber der zeigt
auch alle möglichen schalt und
verteileranlagen also nicht nur
Windparks sondern auch z.B Kohle oder
Atomkraftwerke zweitens ein Windrad
spart pro Jahr zwischen einigen tausend
und über 10 000 Tonnen CO2 ein selbst
wenn das gesamte SF6 aus einem Windrad
also komplett entweichen würde gleich
die Windenergie das durch die
eingesparten CO2 Emissionen innerhalb
von ein bis maximal 2wei Wochen wieder
aus Windräder sind also keine
Klimakiller trotzdem wäre es natürlich
nice wenn wir auf SF6 verzichten könnten
dann müssten wir uns kaum noch Fragen